[MUSIC]
One of the topics that we think is
really interesting is what happens when
CEOs take a very controversial but
personal position on topics
related to the environment or
society or even even political.
And it gets a lot of attention, and
customers and employees see this and
it could have some either positive or
negative consequences on the company.
We're finding it's about maybe 10% or
even less of the CEOs who are engaging
in activism in one form or another.
So it's not like it's everybody doing it,
but
the ones that are doing it tend to
be very well known, very popular.
You know, sometimes founders,
sometimes people that just have had
a visionary impact on the corporation.
[MUSIC]
The types of things we're interested
in are activism by the CEO,
along things that reflect
their personal view.
We're not talking about positions
that the CEO takes, that you can
imagine the position being taken as
one that makes the company better off.
Something like immigration visas for
engineers.
You can imagine companies that are tech
companies, that's a really good thing and
they may be controversial.
But it's really something that
would help them as a company.
So one thing that's interesting based
on our surveys, is there's certain
topics that society seems to want people
to weigh in on and other topics not.
So topics like healthcare, clean energy,
environments seem to be very,
very popular but things like abortion,
religion, politics, things like that.
They tend to want the CEOs
of stay out of that.
So something like I think we
all agree is really important
to talk about gun control.
You know, it's a super controversial area,
especially depending on what
part of the country you're from.
And so, you know,
do you want to take a take a stance or
potentially fund some
initiative on gun control?
Well, you know, you're going
to have a lot of employees and
customers that will find
that to be a good thing and
others that find that to be something
you ought of really stay out of.
[MUSIC]
So CEOs are much more visible,
there's a lot more eyes on them.
So when CEOs are activists,
they take a very personal position
on a controversial topic.
It shows up almost immediately.
The velocity of social media is such
that you can go from nothing to
something pretty serious in
a matter of minutes or hours and
that can explode either in good ways or
bad ways.
[MUSIC]
If you take a position that most customers
don't agree with, you could lose sales.
Or if you take a position that's not
consistent with what employees want,
you could have a hard time attracting and
retaining employees.
And one of the things we're doing now is
taking a look at what happens to sales and
purchases of companies typically
in the retail space but
where CEOs taken a very strong
position on a controversial topic.
Did the sales go up or
down, things like that.
If you take a stance on something,
you can start,
doing some arithmetic what
customers might we lose?
Or what customers might we
gain by doing these things?
Same thing on the employee side.
There are some employees who
will be turned off by this and
maybe leave and
others will be attracted to it.
The flip side of it is, and
we've done some surveys,
what you find is that about two-thirds of
the people want the CEOs take a leadership
position of some of these controversial
environmental social issues.
It varies a bit, depending on your
political affiliation, or what generation
you're in, whether you're a boomer, or
a gen x'er, or millennial, or whatever.
But if the cost and
benefits are something you want to
think about, it's hard to quantify.
But it may be the case that
companies are wanting to maybe take
a hit in terms of the economics, but
actually do something really good for
the environment or other stakeholders.
One thing that we find in the research
is some early indications
that consumers are willing to buy
more from companies that take
an activist position on
positions that they agree with.
We find the flip side as well,
that they're likely to buy less from
companies that take the activist position
on something that they disagree with.
So I mean, these positions can
shift customer purchases, and
ultimately it affects
the bottom line of the company.
[MUSIC]
The one thing I think is really
key is that the board in
the governance structure
of the organization.
You have to anticipate these things and
they want to talk about it ahead
of time and not be blindsided.
I think the smart boards are actually kind
of going through a bit of scenarios where
what will we do if.
I think the boards really
need to think about,
do they want the CEO making personal
statements about these things or not.
And one push back might be well,
it's the CEO saying it,
it's his personal opinion or
her personal opinion.
But really, it's hard to
separate the CEO of the company
as a person from the company itself.
So that can either be a good thing or
a bad thing.
You want to put a kind
of constraints on them,
kind of lay that out in a formal way.
And then if you take these positions,
you might want to think
about what's cost of benefits
of doing that for shareholders.
So it's complicated.
[MUSIC]
So the role of board is tricky and
it's evolving, especially now.
Companies have historically been in the US
at least focused on shareholder value.
More recently, some of the big
institutional investors like Larry Fink
at BlackRock have sent
letters out to board say hey,
you have to take these other
stakeholders into account.
Customers, employees, the society,
environment and even the government.
So I mean there's push to sort of
change from a strict shareholder focus.
In that kind of setting you can imagine
CEOs advocating certain positions
that they view as better for society and
kind of embrace the stakeholders views.
Where it's like let's really start paying
serious attention to environment or
workplace diversity or things like that.
So I think it's going to be interesting
to see how the board's focus changes.
And I think it's going to be interesting
to see how CEOs respond, but
it's an evolution.
[MUSIC]
You could imagine at some point,
people demanding here are these
topics that we feel strongly
about as customers and employees.
What is your stance on this kind of thing?
There's a lot of things that would
probably make the environment
better off that are very costly.
Where the value to shareholders
is probably not positive.
That's where it becomes very,
very complicated.
You're willing to make those investments,
just because it's the right thing
to do for those stakeholders.
And that whole thing has to be mapped out.
It was certainly a lot more discussion
about stakeholder interest now.
You know, people investing
in environmental, social and
government sorts of funds.
And more money pouring into that,
you know, type of thing.
You're going to have a whole
new generation of board members
that sort of understand this stuff,
grew up with it.
And it think it's going to
change the discussion.
It'll be interesting to see how
that plays out going forward.
[MUSIC]